hallo herzlich willkommen zur nächsten
trainingseinheit wir machen euch fit wir
halten euch fit heutiger schwerpunkt ist
ein kraft ausdauertraining wo man den
fokus definitiv auf die beinmuskulatur
legen werden wir haben eine spezial
geister bei einem golfprofi den
corporate team an
der mangel ist da ich bin dort peter und
gemeinsam werden die nächste halbe
stunde schauen dass die oberschenkel zum
glühen beginnen
am besten ist bevor man loslegen aber
team unterstellst die kurz vor hallo wie
schon erwähnt ich bin der teamarbeit im
profi golf spielt auf der challenge tour
ist die zweite tour in europa und spiele
für den golf gucke nur auf un ebene
heeressportler im leistungszentrums in
der südstadt okay seit wann spielst du
golf also ich bin wirklich golf seitdem
ich ein kleines kind bin also es gibt
kein wirkliches anfangs datum
sorgenkinder rhein geboren worden
und ja meine eltern spielen golf ja
beide also vor allem mein papa aber in
eine mama auch ein bisschen und die
haben sie auch so kennengelernt also ihr
kennt gemeinsam auch am sonntag einen
golf ausflug machen wenn es erlaubt ist
und wenn es möglich ist dann ist das
natürlich auch eine sehr feine sache
okay meine durch stimme golf gespielt
die erfahrungen sind dass er zwei
geteilt einen profi und dann nicht ganz
so motivierten golfer aber dass unser
werk hat nicht schmälern
wir fangen an mit einem lockeren
aufwärmprogramm das ist wir laufen uns
einfach mehr ein
am stand laufen geht schon los machst du
parallel zu deinem golftraining
athletiktraining dazu ja schon also
gerade im winter im sommer ist nicht
ganz so viel zeit wenn man doch die
ganze zeit unterwegs ist eigentlich also
das ist wirklich so von frühling bis
herbst die hochsaison
und da bleibt nicht ganz so viel zeit
weil die turniere sehr zeitintensiv sind
aber sonst im winter ist schon sehr viel
sehr viel athletik training das
verändert sich im golfsport grad extrem
okay das heißt hier geht's genauso in
die kraftkammer geht es genauso
ausdauertraining an
na ja also es ist wirklich das da hat es
in den letzten jahren gerade durch tiger
wurzeln extremen extremen wechsel geben
die ja zum teil fertigen goldwert immer
vielleicht noch im kopf hat die werden
immer weniger
ok und möchte wie gesagt eine große
athletin jahr ist sehr groß locker
machen die beine kreis man mal die arme
vorwärts denken so die beweglichkeit
gerade aus den armen und aus der
wirbelsäule ist er sicherlich was was
ihr als golfer tagtäglich aber auch zur
total also das ist wirklich das ist
einfach wichtig wenn man ein paar eine
gewisse distanz schlagen will oder auch
muss einfach sagen dass man da dass man
relativ bewege ich in der
brustwirbelsäule und nach innen in den
schultern ist ja ok wie gesagt ein
schwerpunkt des heutigen trainings sind
die beine weil das natürlich auch für
den golfer jetzt nicht gerade vom marsch
von loch zu loch sondern eben in der
dynamik des anschlags ist ein sehr
wichtiger punkt ist und deswegen schauen
wir uns das heute einem detail an wie
das ganze ausschauen kann locker machen
wir die arme aus marl die heiße visuelle
mobilisieren blick wendung linke seite
auf die rechte seite und ich glaube gott
die visuelle das ist also knackpunkt der
bisher bei den golfern oder ja also das
ist wirklich auch bei mir ich habe
leider auch bisherigen probleme gehabt
in letzter zeit blick wendung nach oben
und nach unten
das ist wirklich das ist die häufigste
verletzung oder generell die belastung
einfach durch die rotation belastung ist
die belastung die auf die wirbelsäule
kommt schon geradezu spitzenbereich
extrem rock'n'roller noch von der linken
seite über die brust auf die rechte
seite und hin und her
das heißt wir werden unser worker
entsprechend anpassen eine mischung aus
bein training und rumpf training sodass
er die man entsprechend wirklichen
mehrwert aus der trainingseinheit auch
mitnehmen kann
das passt dann glaube ich in deinen
trainingstag ganz gut hinein wobei immer
sicher bin das wird sicher nicht die
letzte einheit heute sein okay
halswirbelsäule hammer wie wir am besten
den bereich der gesamten wirbelsäule
brust über seite und lendenwirbelsäule
auf was ist da eine übung die du gerne
mache ich zum beispiel ich mache ich es
gern extrem gern das heißt open books
also gelernter legt sich so auf die
seite also ich habe mich auf die seite
weil das das dass das mikrofon und dann
und dann einfach so auf rotieren zum
beispiel
so quasi aus der andere nahe
stellungnahme aufdrehen auch wieder
hinein die dann will die vorschläge
machen wir das gleich die übung mit in
unser repertoire an diversesten
mobilisation übungen für die wirbelsäule
nach unten drehen kann man noch eigens
ausstrecken fenster nach oben nimmt dann
ist so ein bisschen schwieriger wäre
dann wirklich so ganz auf grand wechsel
hat die seite jetzt das ganze erste
rückgang sicht wirbelsäule bewegt sie
wirklich fast über den gesamten bereich
von der lendenwirbelsäule bis zu heiß
über säule die kopf wendung die blick
wendung ist mit dabei das ist eine
komplexe übung für die gesamte
wirbelsäule
ok ich würd vorstand stehen wir wieder
auf schauen wir dass man den kreislauf
in schwung bringen
so wie üblich jetzt mittlerweile schon
aus dem normalen laufen am stand gegen
einen boxer läuft das ist ein bisschen
art fremde bewegung für dich ja dass man
das sehen dass das auch jeder man machen
kann das heißt boxer los du kannst auf
jeden zweiten schritt schlagen du kannst
auf jeden schritt schlagen alle
möglichkeiten hamada es ist einfach nur
wichtig oberkörper also die arme und die
beine im koordiniert gleichzeitig zu
bewegen sondern schaue man auch in der
nächsten übung dass man bislang
dynamisch reinkriegen in dem bereich
rotation das heißt leichte geräte
schritt öffnung und oberkörper in
vorhalte linke hand zum rechten bein und
umgekehrt hin und her rotieren
es funktioniert ja du hast mir verzählt
du hast da eine verletzung im bereich
der lendenwirbelsäule sie erst vor
kurzem gehabt ist es so weit ausgeheilt
das du sagst du bist wieder voll
leistungsfähig und kannst voll
trainieren am voll trainieren leider
noch nicht also ich habe es mit neujahr
sozusagen angefangen
bälle zu schlagen auf der range und
zwischenzeitig aufrichten aus lockern
gerade noch so dabei wieder auf dem
vollen level zu kommen feinschliff das
wieder 24 13 jahre lang wird das nur
daran also prinzipiell wäre unsere
saison jetzt im februar in südafrika
losgegangen ist jetzt verschoben worden
auf april
die turniere werden sowieso zu früh für
mich kaum an jetzt hoffe ich dass ich
bis april also für diesen block dann
quasi das produkt im unglück so quasi
das turnier wurde verschoben und du
kannst dein verletzungen objektiv aus
hama kamen kammer fasst zusammen was
wohl eher sehen sich langsam aber sehr
okay was hilft reiter stand hände aufs
knie gelenk und wir kreisen aus dem
kniegelenk mobilisieren das kniegelenk
richtung wechseln und wieder kurz
aufrichten hat das linke bein hoch
kreisen im sprunggelenk ich denke die
dynamik der bewegung beim golfen braucht
sie das gleichgewicht auch ja schon
wichtig weil du weil du heute das
gleichgewicht im schwung erhalten muss
dass er eine gute aus produzierte
bewegung zusammen bringen es da auch
alleine schon im verein wechseln
aber es ist sicherlich nicht das
hauptaugenmerk will ich sie dazu bringen
aber im hause fliegen sicher andere
sportarten wo das wichtige und wieder
ausloggen
dann nehmen wir noch eine übung becken
kreisen dass die kein zurück die hände
in die hüfte stellen und entsprechend
mit kleinen kreisen beginnen und dann
immer größer werden
richtung wechseln
kurz wieder phase aktivieren stand live
geht schon los auf start ab wie viel
schneller werden auf stopp wieder
langsam weiter laufen bereits start und
stop & start stop start stop kurz aus
locker handy zusammen handgelenk kreisen
richtung wechseln hände seitlich hoch
geben und den unterarm kreisen album
aktivieren album schauen dass man
entsprechend vorbereiten auf die
belastung die kommt richtung wechseln
und ausloggen ok und damit sie ja die
leute zu hause was vorstellen könne
niemand du bist gleich achtmal
staatsmeister waren im golfen ja also
als amateur bei uns ist das metamaterial
profilbilder kompliziertes konstrukt
aber als amateur bester golfer gewesen
genauso ist es in jugend und nimmt dann
im herrenbereich der herrenbereich war
nachdem er damit 22 bin ich pro pro
waren oder einfach nicht mehr so lang
gewesen ist dann was genau so lang
gewesen aber ja okay ich würde
vorschlagen einmal soweit allgemein
aufgewärmt wir machen jetzt ein kurzes
aktivieren für die rumpfmuskulatur auf
wunsch vom team an weil das ist genauso
1 was er jetzt braucht einen starken
rumpf ein starken chor um entsprechend
danach wieder möglichst rasch schnell
fit zu werden
wir fangen an unterstützt 30 sekunden
danach 30 sekunden fliegender wechsel
seit schilds fliegender wechsel
rücklings und dann die andere seite es
als zwei minuten spannung im rumpf ab
jetzt auch hier
ich wiederholte dass beginnend bei der
schulter über das gesäß kniegelenk
sprunggelenk ihr müsst eine stabile
ebene haben dahinter schaut nicht nach
oben der körper hängt nicht nach unten
durch ihr seid stabil fünf sekunden dann
wechsele man die position in der seite
stütze noch 21 wechselt auch hier der
kopf in verlängerung der wirbelsäule und
die hand kennzahl bis als parameter
nehmen schwierig nach oben schwierig
über kopf etwas einfacher wenn man sie
runter gibt und abwickelt die variante
entscheidet ihr welche dass ihr nehmt
das ist definitiv eine die man machen
kann
nach fünf sekunden bereit machen für den
wechsel auf die rückseite hintere muss
ich hätte jetzt die macht der gewohnheit
anscheinend du hast die zweite seite
genommen ja der mann hat die rückgabe
ist alles gut der mann hat die rückseite
genommen bleibt kopf in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule becken hoch volle spannung
aus dem körper heraus zehn sekunden
auch bei dir thiemann kopf in
verlängerung das heißt genau schauen
nach oben sehr gehört fünf sekunden 21
wechsel letzte seite letzten 30 sekunden
für das aktivieren der rumpfmuskulatur
schöne spannung halten
eine aktiv rumpf aktiv unterstützt genau
das ist es was jetzt wichtig ist um
diese aktivierung auch zu erreichen
sie konnten und auf kurzem aus lockern
ausschied und durchschnaufen bevor man
loslegt kennst gern noch ein schluck
trinken und befeuchten und dann sah man
bereit und fahren mit unserem
kraftausdauer workout an die erste übung
wird sein der ausfallschritt auf der
linken seite mit einer rotation aus dem
oberkörper als er ist jetzt für bauen
dort diese rotation wieder mit ein was
für den golfspieler ganz ganz wichtig
ist das heißt kombinierte übung
beweglichkeit wirbelsäule stabile score
system und aktivieren der beine
man darf sie bitten dass du diesen
vorzeichen genau hier geht's in den
ausfallschritt hinein und droht jetzt
den oberkörper auf die seite zurück und
richtet euch wieder auf 30 sekunden lang
arbeitet man das ganze ab und in 10
sekunden staat machen darf ich bitten
dass wir bisher nach vor rutscht das man
gut sieht drei sekunden 21 uhr los
geht's auch hier wichtig wenn ihr den
ausfallschritt macht schaut das stabile
beinachse habe dass das knie nicht nach
ihnen nach außen weg gibt der oberkörper
bleibt aktiviert und aufrecht und geht
in die rotation hinein halbzeit 15
sekunden zweimal durch nach fünf
sekunden 21 und aussagen kurths
entspannungsphase 30 sekunden
wir setzen gleich fort mit dem
seitenwechsel das heißt wir machen
gleich die zweite seite und diejenigen
von euch zu hause die jetzt da das
gefühl haben naja diese dynamische
bewegung in den ausfallschritt hinein
bis es mal 30 sekunden zu lang geht es
in die position bleibt vorne runter
gehen verdrehen zurückdrehen aufrichten
ohne den schritt dazu ist genauso
möglich
ok dann stark war wieder fünf sekunden
nach bereit machen so eins und los
geht's gleichgewicht halten ist wichtig
versucht es aber immer wieder
auszugleichen
konzentriert sein und trotzdem dynamisch
arbeiten
was wir heute am programm standen themen
beine oder oberkörper heute oberkörper
am nachmittag auf dem programm standen
natürlich kurzfristig eingesprungen
vom vermieter golftraining gehabt
nachmittag oberkörper sei das aus 30
sekunden durch kurz entspannen
aber ich werde mein oberkörper
durchziehen wird nicht genau
ok ausfallschritt der hammer nächste
übung haben wir für die gesäßmuskulatur
oberschenkelrückseite und den unteren
rücken genau das was eben wie gesagt der
timon jetzt braucht aufgrund von seiner
verletzung im bereich der
lendenwirbelsäule
gleichwohl müsse man schauen dass man
das muskelpaket um richtig richtig
kräftig hingelegt dass er wieder die
volle leistung drinnen ist das heißt
einmal bitte auf die matte rückenlage
wie wenn ihr euch quasi hinlegen wollte
es mit abgewinkelten beinen fest am
boden
das heißt die zehenspitzen schauen nach
oben becken kann es nach oben und nach
unten drücken das ganze in einer
einbeinigen variante auch möglich und
die die da richtig feuer auf der
muskulatur haben können auch ein
zusatzgewicht verwenden das heißt das
stört man sie dann auf den oberkörper
auf die hüfte und gadgets 30 sekunden
arbeiten einbeinige die post geht schon
los
da immer wieder schauen in die
vollstreckung das heißt den hintern auch
voll anspannen halbzeit ist erledigt mit
zusatzgewicht von 30 sekunden ein wenig
richtig richtig anstrengend aber
natürlich auch ohne zusatzgewicht habe
auch gute belastung auf meiner
gesäßmuskulatur oberschenkelrückseite
und unterer rücken 30 sekunden zweimal
durch kurze pause gewicht vielleicht
kurz abstellen
ihr kennt ja in der position bleiben
weil wir machen natürlich gleich die
zweite seite dazu dass linke seite
zuerst und jetzt die rechte seite mit
einer verletzung geht das ist es okay
die übung ja jetzt wieder also jetzt
wieder ganz am anfang werde natürlich
nicht gar nicht kann aber jetzt kommt
einer stadium wo es solche übungen
wieder möglichst super passt dann macht
man es bereits drei sekunden zweiter
durchgang und geht schon los 30 sekunden
ein
einiges heben des beckens generell diese
übungen seien natürlich jetzt nicht nur
dem golfprofi vorbehalten sondern auch
für euch zu hause um mich fit zu halten
wo manch leistungsfähig zu machen oder
zu halten und entsprechend auch da
präventiv zu arbeiten vorbeugend zu
arbeiten eben wenn man noch keine
verletzung im rücken hatte dass man die
annett kriegt zwei sekunden auch gewicht
abstellen
30 sekunden arbeitszeit sind erledigt
wobei ihr könnt gerne kurz aufstehen und
auch auflockern aber wir bleiben auf der
matte weil wir gehen jetzt in den sommer
hinein wir haben seitliche spannung und
das machen wir jetzt gleich warum
spannung gibt es die alternative die der
golfer dazu machen kann so zur website
stütz umsatzes generell alles was mit
mit dein abheben ob das jetzt das obere
bayern oder das untere bayern alles was
die übung in irgendeiner form komplexer
macht ist für euch wichtig genauso wie
sie dann würde ich vorschlagen wenn man
diesen ratschlag lernen das heißt aus
dem salzstock eben mal das untere
beinahe mühelos 30 sekunden arbeitszeit
genau jetzt volle spannung aus der
rumpfmuskulatur gerade stabiler körper
kopf in verlängerung der wirbelsäule und
das untere bein zieht jetzt nach oben
das heißt einerseits eine extrem
statische belastung von meinem standbein
sozusagen und in die dynamische
belastung von meinem spiel beim wichtig
becken strecken du hast hintern spannen
21 zeitig aus 30 sekunden pause so
richtig anstrengend zweite seite machen
wir gleich dazu ja ein anerkennendes
nicken für die übung die gibt richtig
gas das ist mangel oder habe das richtig
interpretiert ja genau zehn sekunden hat
bereitmachen positionen einnehmen
nach 321 spannung aufbauen und geht's
los
becken nach vor hintern anspannen
zwischenstand bein und schulter quasi
die gerade die ebene wieder aufspannen
kopf bleibt in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule auf der es einmal wieder
achten wenn es notwendig ist die
position kurz nach justieren wenn das
beinahe weggerutscht
es ist gerade auf der matte oft sehr
schwierig weil die belastung natürlich
strecken die gegner verlängerung ein
und das muss man dann körperlich
entsprechend umsetzen
zwei sekunden jetzt ist aus not
geschafft meinen aufstehen aus organza
linke seite rechte seite haben wir somit
das heißt wir sind bereits sechs übungen
durch die übung ein klassiker erkennt
sie in kniebeuge das heißt darauf achten
beinachse bleibt stabil
das gesetz geht so weit runter was eure
beweglichkeit zulässt das heißt am
besten natürlich ganz hinunter wenn das
aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht möglich
ist dann hört seit genau drauf was die
beweglichkeit einschränkt wie
zusatzgewicht möglich und cashflows 30
sekunden arbeitszeit
da kann man natürlich noch mal
zusätzlich habe bislang reiz setzen wenn
man ein gewicht in die hand nimmt sei es
eine kette bed sex ertrag an wasser
der angestellte rucksack was auch immer
kann ich natürlich meine belastung noch
einmal steigern
zehn sekunden nach
212 disco zeit ist aus gewicht sauber
kontrolliert wieder absetzen und
vorbereiten auf den einband stand wie
gesagt für den golfer zwar nicht das
aller aller wichtigste das gleichgewicht
aber wir können jetzt das kombinieren
gleichgewicht und kraftentwicklung
wiederum aus der beinmuskulatur und aus
dem gesäß mit den einbeinigen good
morning das heißt eine rücken und gesäß
übung sagt uns das einmal vor bittet die
man ohne gewicht einfach so runter also
kann man das wird schon mit gewicht kann
man einfach so entstand in der waage
gerne auch nach oben quasi in die stadt
lage gehen mit gewicht vor dem körper
oder auch ohne werkzeug der firma
dennree morgens gleich 30 sekunden
arbeiten ihm die waage hineingehen genau
wieder aufrichten das aber im unteren
rücken drinnen im standbein natürlich
muskulär auch voll zu stabilisieren und
arbeit der übung ganz wichtig die
kontrollierte stabile gerade bei einer
achse
das müsst einfach immer wieder checken
bei euch selbst zwei sekunden
und seit es aus 30 sekunden haben wir
wieder zweite seite ist offen
das heißt noch einmal kurz ausprobieren
zweite seite wechseln
15 sekunden legen nämlich gleich wieder
los ist es auf der pro tour also geht es
hier von loch zu loch zum entspannen zum
regenerieren oder vorziehe man also wenn
nicht wirklich weg zwischen den löchern
unüberschaubares dass es von den von den
zeiten her ganz blöd wer dann geht man
alles sehr gut okay da wird gern gibt es
keine e cars oder sonstige sachen die
man für ok bereitmachen gewicht in die
hand nehmen und geht schon los
das kommt zwar nicht in eine
ausdauerbelastung hinein die an
trainings wirksamen reiz aber bewegt ihr
satz unterwegs an der frischen luft und
das ist natürlich auch gegen wir gerade
in der jetzigen zeit ein sehr wichtiger
aspekt ein sehr wichtiger punkt total ja
und auch man darf nicht unterschätzen
also manchmal bewegt sich wenn man
wirklich 18 loch und seil aus spielt
dann dann bewegt man sich das schon
richtig vieles können je nach platz
zwischen 8 und 10 km wirklich seinem
motorrad rückblick deutlich schöner
distanz ja da verbrennt man schon noch
ein paar kalorien nicht das ist klar
letzte übung im ersten durchgang der
seestern eine übung für die
rückenmuskulatur eine komplexe übung das
heißt in bauchlage arme und beine öffnen
wie wie beim seestern quasi das war dass
sie ihren stern marktmeinung tag x vor
das heißt die cec nach oben öffnet die
arme und die beine und beim runtergehen
im wechsel quasi wieder schließen bereit
machen
wir legen teil wieder los in 21 und los
geht's da muss man dann schon ein
bisschen mitdenken das thema hochheben
eröffnen geöffnet runter geöffnet hoch
und wieder zu machen
so könnte man das im wechsel ganz
schnell zusammenfassen das ist oft gar
nicht so einfach dass dein körper das
macht was an der kopf danach vorgibt
zehn sekunden noch und zeit ist aus
kurze pause aufstehen aus lockern
ausschütteln vielleicht am stand ein
bisschen gehen oder in der wohnung im
büro aber ist ein hin und her gehen die
beine aus lockern und ausschütten
ich glaube das ist das jetzt was man am
meisten braucht hüfte kreisen so einfach
dass man sie kurzer bisher regeneriert
und wohlfühlen kann
golf spielen kann man ja ein prinzipiell
ins hohe alter
was hast du geplant wie lang möchtest du
golf spiele das kann ich so noch nicht
sagen aber prinzipiell also ich sage
jetzt wirklich leistungsmäßig am
höchsten niveau ist es auf jeden fall
bis 45 bis 47 möglich
dann kommt er so die vorbereitung fall
des willens wollen nicht alle
dass sie sich dann noch mal auf die
seniors tour des 50plus vorbereiten und
dort dann noch einmal durchstarten weil
einfach ab 45 traditionelle plätze
die dann auch auf der haupt tour
gespielt werden zu lang werden länge
verliere alter und sich dann eher schon
auf diesen satz lag länge melden
also wirklich die schlag länge also wenn
ich jetzt einen versuch so weit wie
möglich zu schlagen der ball ungefähr
kann man sich vorstellen so 280 meter
und im alter wenn man dann nicht mehr
ganz so beweglich wird vielleicht ein
bisserl kraft verliert dann geht das
bild zurück richtung vielleicht 240 250
und das macht uns schon ein großer
anreiz schwierig da diese plätze
bewältigt neuer ja gut da wir bislang
ein blick ist im golfsport mir gänzlich
unberührt was das betrifft noch aber
vielleicht probiere das einmal außen her
wird weil es sehr viele fälle sehr
spannender guter ersatz bereit zu hause
wir machen den zweiten durchgang wir
beginnen wieder mit ausfallschritte mit
rotation linke seite nach vor und geht
fast 30 sekunden arbeitszeit
[Applaus]
15 sekunden habt so das heißt
durchbeißen und versuchte eine
dynamische gleichförmige bewegung zu
haben das ist rein drehen raus drin
hochkommen eine flüssige bewegung an
schwung in der bewegung 30 sekunden
haben wir durch kurz durch lockern und
die zweite seite vorbereiten
jetzt macht mal rechte seite nach vor
und die rotation natürlich dann in die
andere richtung
kannst du mit der zweiten hand also wenn
du eine hauptlast beim golfspielen mit
der anderen seite spielen bei den
spielern dass sie einmal recht spiel und
dann links probieren und ein bisschen
geht es beim golf war ja also prinz war
also man kann sich fast nicht lage in
diese richtung ja und das wäre dann
genau umgekehrt gibt so einige wie es
ist beides möglich in diese richtung ist
im golf nicht nicht eigentlich nicht
nicht sehr gefragt da wo wir jetzt
natürlich hier und da war man blödelt
aus statt mit der zweiten seite dort zu
arbeiten
aber ich würde sagen dass da bin ich
eher am anfang an anfänger level
das heißt wenn die dann theoretisch
jetzt golfspiel und beginne und wir
treffen uns in zwei autonome dann schlug
mir wahrscheinlich mit einer schwachen
seite immer noch aber es ist zu mir das
so dass nicht ganz blamabel ist ja da
können wir dann unser abend das nicht
viel nur sehr interessantes match 5
sekunden und sein aus kurz durch lockern
wir wechseln wieder unsere position auf
die matte wir gehen wieder in das becken
heben aus der rückwärtigen position
entweder mit zusatzgewicht oder auch
ohne beide varianten sind möglich macht
sich bereit
21 und becken heben ein wenig oder auch
bei nick ist möglich schön in die
streckung hineingehen wirklich am
obersten punkt auch immer wieder das
gesäß anspannen so kommen wirklich in
eine perfekte hüft streckung hinein und
das ist ja das was man jetzt erreichen
wollen muskuläre belastung und wie
gesagt aus der vollstreckung in der
hüfte
sehen sie konnten nach
das sieht man schon stand bei anfangs
zum zittern aber es ist schon richtig
anstrengen ja zwei sekunden eine zeit
ist durch 30 sekunden auslagern
ausschütteln und die zweite vorbereiten
das heißt deine eltern haben ab
profimäßig gespielt oder mein papa ja
mal garnicht aber mein papa profimäßig
gespielt somit ist es in die wiege
gelegt und du hast eigentlich gar nicht
anders kennen und so ist es ja das von
ihm gott zu danken ihren druck kann man
also das wollte ich schon selber so zwei
sekunden eine und los geht's natürlich
also wie gesagt und zwingend auf seinem
hohen niveau jemanden sportler betreiben
das geht also wie sondern da muss ja
sehr viel freude enthusiasmus und
begeisterung mit dabei sein weil es uns
ist marianne dem stande dieses
trainingspensum absolvieren
ich hab das deine leistungssport
kollegen auch gefragt wie viel stunden
trainierst du in der woche kann man das
zusammenschlossen
das kommt wirklich sehr von woche zu
woche darauf an in der turnierwoche
nachdem allein eine rundenzeit ist durch
zwischen fünf und sechs stunden kommt
[Applaus]
ist es halt bei uns auch nachdem die
diese grund intensität der zum vergleich
zu schwimmen oder oder was wir sich zu
den meisten anderen sparten sei relativ
gering wenn die amaryllis lange bereit
islam marinieren und sogar da kannst du
auch sein dass ich dann im sommer
wirklich den ganzen tag am golfplatz
verbringen und dann schaue dass ich noch
eine fitnesseinheit reinbringen wechseln
derzeit stützt das nicht vor plaudern
dass man das werk hat mir das ablassen
genau und beim hochziehen
also immer in einer heftigen woche kann
schon sein dass man 40 50 stabil halten
bis sie nach vor drehen am kanal zur
bringt ja das ist dann schon eine sehr
lange zeit
das geht wieder recht 5 sekunden und
seite wechseln
ich habe für euch jederzeit natürlich
nimmt sich einen schluck macht eine
kurze pause
30 sekunden habe sowieso zeit in die
nächste übung das geht sie auch bereit
machen noch 5 und catch los arbeitszeit
unteres beim hochheben sollte sich das
von der stabilität wenn ich mal ganz
ausgehen stellt zweimal das untere bein
ab und hebt das obere bein hoch es wird
schon jetzt richtige anstrengend für die
rumpfmuskulatur und auch für die beine
wer also nicht nur beim team und bei
mangel sondern ich bin sicher bei euch
zu hause auch fünf sekunden 2 1 2 das
aus drei übungen bleiben uns noch
wir starten die nächste kniebeugen
variante nehmt euch euer zusatzgewicht
oder auch nicht wichtig ist wenn ihr
zusatzgewicht verwendet hebt das mit den
stabilen geraden rücken hoch das tor
beginnt bereits das werk hat beim
anheben des gewichts geht schloss
vorbereiten und 30 sekunden zeit läuft
und ich wiederhole mich da auch gerne
wenn die kniebeuge tief ist und
kontrolliert ist die beinachse passt ist
es perfekt und wenn sie auf der hälfte
aufhört oder weiter oben auf diversen
gründen beweglichkeit kraft oder
vielleicht hat man irgendwann einmal
verletzung gehabt und ist dadurch
eingeschränkt weiter oben aufhört
wichtig ist dass wir überhaupt das macht
das sich bewegt und trainiert und die 30
sekunden haben wir wieder erledigt das
heißt gewicht bitte abstellen und noch
einmal das gleichgewicht aktivieren weil
wir gehen wieder in den einband stand
die einbeinigen good morning das hat das
aufrichten aus der waagerechten wo man
die belastung dann wiederum in den
rücken hinein kriegen und in die
beinmuskulatur das braucht man
das war das ziel heute macht euch bereit
ein wenig und geht schon los auch stabil
hier aus dem oberkörper aus dem rumpf
nicht vertreten sondern möglichst gerade
bleiben auch auf der seite wo es gewicht
ist dann nicht nachgeben sondern
wirklich die spannung groß und aufrecht
halten kopf bleibt in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule netz schauen was passiert da
vor dahinter links oder rechts sondern
wirklich entspannt der halswirbelsäule
dass man doch nicht in eine
entsprechende verspannung dann hinein
kommen 30 minuten hammer kurz
durchschnitt und kurz durch lockern und
dann gehen wir die zweite seite an ran
und dann bleibt uns noch das seestern
als allerletzte übung und dann haben wir
unser rücken und beine training schon
wieder erledigt bereitmachen in fünf
sekunden machen wir widerlegen wieder
los und zeit läuft 30 sekunden auch hier
achtet darauf arbeite jetzt schon
anstrengend wird dass die position
sauber ist das da rücken gerade ist dass
das bein hinten hoch kommt also achtet
auf diese bewegungs knotenpunkte dass
die passen mangel pass auf das nicht zu
weit runter gehe ist das schön gerade
bleibst genau sehr gut drei sekunden
dann ist die übung schon wieder vorbei
fünf sekunden noch nach 321 und gewicht
braucht man keines mehr
das bitte auf die seite stellen und
jetzt da geht es in die letzte übung
noch für den rückenstrecken bzw auch
gesäßmuskulatur ist mit dabei seestern
letzte übung für heute 30 sekunden name
konzentrieren 30 sekunden haben wir noch
eine belastung und dann haben wir es
geschafft vorbereiten ausgangsposition
zeit läuft 30 sekunden
schlafen bewegen nicht reißen die
bewegung sondern mit der kraft arbeiten
sehen sie konnten nur 5 321 worker dies
durch heike thiemann fürs mitmachen
danke meiner lagers vor zeigen und
mitmachen wir haben 30 minuten für die
beine für unseren ruf gearbeitet was
möchtest du den leuten damit geben wir
heute sie die fed am besten im lokal ja
einfach jede möglichkeit die man hat
sich irgendwie fit zu halten egal ob in
der wohnung im haus draußen natürlich
immer unter abstands einhaltung einfach
nutzen
ja und schauen dass man was für ein
körper tut ständigen auf der couch
liegen macht auch nicht besser also von
dem den inneren schweinehund überwinden
dass zumindest alle sportorganisationen
wochen haben wir rausgehen aber mit uns
mittrainieren und seien in diesem
wechsel drinnen dann kommt man da schon
ganz gut und väter aus dieser
schwierigen zeit heraus okay es war
wieder eine besondere trainingseinheit
mit spezialgast dem thema als
profigolfer wir freuen uns auf die
nächste einheit wir freuen uns auf
morgen und wünschen euch noch einen
schönen tag